this summer five years in the league
he's increased his scoring average every
year
including this one
stance
[Music]
that may be the prettiest part of the
game but he got out late
now you gotta get back on iguodala and
oh
they'll slam it home over luke evans
tried to help but it was a poster anyway
the defense we're doing a great job on
blake we just got to keep playing
now we said before the game we were not
going to ask you about your texts
and then you go and get another tag what
happened on christmas night
through it into no man's land
andre iguodala showing tremendous
girl green and marcus morris let down on
the foul
you've got to complete the foul you
can't allow the foul to just be soft
footer right there that he passed up and
that hurts you if you can't
shoot the ball reversing up and in
what a baseline drive
[Applause]
and back of the warriors iguodala puts a
move on
the double behind
[Applause]
look out andre iguodala the former u of
a star
this and the rebound good job
[Applause]
godallah attacking and finishing
just a bit of separation as the warrior
league grows to four
stingadala makes big plays in big times
[Applause]
break points stop on one end slam on the
other
that was missing
[Applause]
dropping it for david lee to lay it up
and in
the open floor they finish in
really fun style
mike woodholzer's gonna be really happy
right now because this second unit has
just kind of clawed back into the game
to the rim with
[Applause]
number one field goal percentage defense
number one and fast break points
trying to disrupt steph curry up with
the ball
all these picks can be switched
[Applause]
from this year
they said their intent of play over the
last few weeks has been
fantastic as again you see steph just
with that flick heads up to get it to
andre
maybe got fouled on that play but he
normally leads to an easy shot there's a
turn over there
and iguodala beats everyone down the
score and hammers it home
ma'am's taking 20 second time durant
up top iguodala durant finds a goodall
goes inside and throws it down
said the other day that he's still angry
he was only second team all defense last
year
as jeromeko finishes off the gorgeous
delivery
from iguodala the way that this unit on
the floor for the warriors will beat you
is
pushing it in transition unselfish
players iguodala with the beautiful drop
off pass behind the back
and girepko does the rest
gets the shot knocked away nicely by
thompson
trippers battle for it can't get it
iguodala will fly
to the basket and throw it down 87
but that put a little bit of passion
back in the attack here
for the golden state warriors iguodala
coast to coast in the throwdown
55 percent of the shots are threes
unheard of
they come to double knock it away curry
the push of him
he get down in transition
[Applause]
you get the steal
double teaming but watch what happens
here iguodala gets a nice scream from
draymond
green and the one defender there can't
recover
and then it's home free for andre and of
course you're gonna get out of the way
rather than as damien dotson did
off meredith's foot knocked away picked
up by iguodala iguodala drives gets
inside layup at the buzzer
it's good and the foul
oh he clearly got it off in time and the
whistle
and iguodala will shoot one free throw
rondo
pass deflected by iguodala
iguodala drives goes inside oh
he throws it down
one of his main guys
a gamble by rondo and a throw down by
iguodala the 35 year old lego dolla
curry trying to get free
curry inside a godella they'll count it
he got it off in time
[Applause]
wow what a screen set on chris paul
raymond green leveled him and that's a
good clean screen
because paul's teammate's responsibility
to communicate and let him know and
iguodala clearly got that off in time
iguodala defended by schaffer three
god he got it buzzer beating triple by
iguodala
halftime for the golden state warriors
often time in town in time
will iguodala foul lillard
almost stolen lewis stolen by iguodala
took him out of his hands
curry from headquarters it's over
golden state survives and wins game two
if he played more during the year would
be first team all defense because when
it matters most
this guy has proven to be an elite
all-time defender great hands
the strip seals the victory outstanding
defense
by andre iguodala